[Musique]
ces quads et même des mines sur les
réseaux sociaux
oui je sais c'est une photo qui tourne
sur internet
blague sursis avec tom jso sauce au
conseil votant en tant que chercheur du
mime et vous les mêmes ça vous sonne une
cloche
[Applaudissements]
à
et si je vous dis mille
et là vous voyez ça ne joue pas bon je
ne veux pas alors un même c'est une
forme de langage propre à l'ère
numérique
concrètement c'est une image accompagnée
d'un texte court simple paul chez est
souvent forte teneur humoristique ou pas
retenu comme un chat le même a plusieurs
vies l'idée est de réutiliser une même
image à toutes les sauces la même image
avec un texte différent souvent
inspirées de la culture web
les mêmes sont aussi devenus de
redoutables outil de propagande
politique de militantisme et dans bien
des cas de désinformation ces
différentes facettes des mêmes la
chercheure mireille lalancette les
connais bienne elle qui les étudie
depuis plusieurs heures
[Musique]
c'est quoi la recette d'un même efficace
qu est ce que ça prend comme un
ingrédient s'apprendre l'humour oui ça
prend des images intéressantes
accrocheuse
ça prend un lien avec l'actualité est
aussi dans certains cas un lien avec la
culture populaire
les simpson qu'il personnalités comme
britney spears ou le fameux gambie cap
louis est le secret d'un même c'est sa
simplicité et sa capacité d'être
réutilisés remixé et c'est de plus en
plus facile d'en concevoir d'en générer
plus facile parce qu'au bout nos
téléphones
on a tout ce qu'il faut et des sites au
créer lui même donc mine générateur ya
même une offre même toutes les photos ou
cherchent à faire un mime sur trudeau
vous n'avez pas besoin de chercher une
image sur le dos il faut aller sont même
générateur vous choisissez une image qui
vous plaît puis vous pouvez faire un
même en créant ou en créant trudeau oui
justement si on parlait de même
politique parce que c'est là où il ya
davantage d informations qui se fait
mais pas tous les mêmes sont ni même de
désinformation dans certains cas ce sont
les mêmes qui vont critiquer qu'ils vont
montrer les paradoxes chez un acteur
politique donc
trudeau se dit environnementalistes mais
là deux avions on va utiliser une partie
d'un élément qui est vrai on va retirer
de son contexte et qu'on voit mettre de
l'avant avec d'autres éléments célèbre
franck auplata d'autres
la main sur la taille du boyfriend et
les principes environnementaux qui sont
critiqués par rapport à avoir deux
avions suis là j'ai déjà vu j'ai déjà vu
sur facebook
deux avions alors qu est un discours
environnementaliste que six cependant
l'analyste attribue aux cahiers cadre à
tout va bien on prend les bonnes
décisions au bon moment et quand je vais
acheter deux navires en place et macron
ils sont prémunis c'est pareil un bon
travail et c'est efficace et très
longtemps par la négative
comment on fait une campagne contre udo
il ya des faits oui il me des femmes de
son cabinet à la porte
il prend des séries comme tous les
animaux et la blâmer froide et comparis
ch est un peu forte
tout cela est vrai mais c'est une façon
de critiquer tronox à son approche
mais on est encore loin de ce qui s'est
vu aux états unis pendant l'élection
présidentielle de 2016
des milliers de même conçu en russie ont
atteint des millions d'internautes
américains selon la recension du comité
du renseignement du congrès leur but
était bien clair susciter la division au
sein de l'électorat mairie sont celui ci
vous le reconnaissez ce même une
opération oui j'ai déjà vu en plus
tellement ironique dépôt est ce que les
gens peuvent faire de l'art de leurs
actions même les premiers ça c'est un
truc de jeux vidéo
j'accroche recensés c'est sur exactement
les poêles à bois trouvé très bon moi
j'essaie d'aller plus dans le choeur de
de l'actualité on peut en avoir aussi
que sont possibles vous le reconnaissez
ça commençait déjà que l'ajustement on
présente comme un super héros on espère
poser sa tête lorsqu'il laisse tomber
son turban qui ont le super repose sur
le corps disparaît en est ainsi je me
moque des ces bâtisseurs néo démocrates
oui ça pourrait être sympa synonyme
étape peut-être ça peut être des gens du
parti où les gens et qui croit que
jacques m le héros au piton vie met de
l'avant
ces jo 2006 ah oui oui c'est vrai qu'est
ce qui vous fait rire là encore des
trucs de policiers beau message avec une
image qui tape dans un communiqué qu'est
ce qui fait que dans le contexte actuel
on en voit de plus en plus de ces mêmes
à saveur politique parce que ça fait
parti d'un discours qu'on veut avoir sur
le monde politique
c'est facile de s'approprier eux mêmes
et c'est facile après ceux de faire
partie d'une communauté de gens qui
tiennent un discours critique sont les
acteurs politiques qui veulent d'une
certaine façon s'impliquer dans ce qu'on
appelle maintenant la culture de la
participation au même c'est une image
qui peut nous faire passer un message un
peu plus complexe qu'une simple blague
cet enfant c'est sûrement manière de
calais jean on de dire dans le fond j'ai
cru de l'enfance et puis quand tu peux
faire ce que veut dire ce qu'on veut à
l'image ça devrait avoisiner claude rich
quelque chose
les policiers eux mêmes une partie de
plus en plus en font des mêmes en génère
des mêmes ce qui est intéressant c'est
qu'on peut aussi passer un message
politique positif avec les mêmes on en
avait vu par exemple lorsqu'on annonce
des nouvelles mesures y avait eu l'appui
baby qui avait été utilisé par le
ministre de la famille
donc c'est une façon aussi de rejoindre
les gens positivement en disant voici ce
qu'est le parti libéral fait le même
vont évoluer
il est à son meilleur actuellement mais
ça va être intéressant de voir comment à
travers les acteurs politiques
ils vont évoluer là que ce soit les
citoyens que ce soit les institutions et
les groupes de pression
comment ils vont réussir à évoluer pour
s'adapter à l'internet
est-ce qu'on a tort de penser que les
mêmes
s'adressent surtout un public qui est
jeune les mignot sont pas tout seuls sur
leur mise à sociaux sont aussi avec
toute une série d'autres gens donc leurs
parents leurs amis leurs familles la
première porte pour entrer dans les
mêmes ces lignes au mais après ça il ya
toute une série d'autres personnes à qui
s'intéresse
[Musique]